en mínimos de popularidad del presidente
del Rey está iberdrogan se presenta a
unas elecciones con sabor a plebiscito
todas estas personas que están aquí para
ellos estos comicios significan el todo
o la nada porque a pesar de la gran
crisis económica que atraviesa el país o
la gestión que hizo el Gobierno con el
terremoto siguen apoyando a su líder y
no concibe en una Turquía sin él también
le apoyan los simpatizantes del partido
ultranacionalista el mhp tal como
ocurrió en la anterior legislatura a
sabiendas que las encuestas indican que
la coalición opositora le saca una
ligera ventaja el presidente ha hecho
gala durante esta campaña de las
múltiples construcciones que se han
hecho en materia de infraestructura de
los proyectos energéticos que ya están
en marcha o de los hallazgos de gas y
petróleo en los últimos meses según el
gobierno dará más Independencia a estos
hallazgos al país en un momento en que
las facturas ya estaban empezando a
ahogar a los habitantes del país
euroasiático por lo tanto ya una sola
semana de acudir a las urnas Estas son
las miles de personas que entre ellas
van a votar al presidente